welcome to this video round two of the
candidates and cantonment disc and the
game to analyze in this video is to pull
off gets talent to former world
champions well in the polo's case it's
not so sure if you how to classify some
is this period of time way had won this
war championship tournament in San Luis
but Island certainly is one of the the
yeah the the some yeah the whole
heritage back from from Steinitz to
Casper off at the 13th ball champion
because kramnik number 14 and 15 and now
cards is the 16 through our champion so
on two of the more experienced players
in this tournament so let's see what
happens i know it had won the first game
against Rome young to have a really good
start and now let's see what happens in
the black game here against a bar off
yet Apollo firm it plays all opening
moves but here we have a reti opening
and this is an interesting news order
really which can have many points one
important point is that if black he
obviously signals the intention with one
d5 if black has planned to play a
certain line here in the Queens gambit
he also needs to be aware that if Y it
starts we'll see for this Queens gambit
can rise any time because white can
easily play d4 at a later stage and he
needs to be aware of all the move order
tricks that come up here on our plate c6
so probably he had the Slav in mind
because D for now with directly
transposed to sloth but right now and
this is why it is an interesting move
order white now has some distinct
alternatives he can instead of play
deform he can play mostly to interesting
moves he can play g3 offering the c-4
porn just as a gambit very often called
the ready gambit black can take the porn
and actually keep it if he wants even
with be five though that is a bit risky
and this is an interesting line that
white can play or there is as another
alternative the moose III and this is
what the pile of plate in the given game
here III has one simple idea and many
yeah more tricky ideas the simple ideas
we just keep the pawn so this is not
going to be lost but it has some finer
points wyd is simply not playing d for
for the moment but keeps this move in
reserve black now um has some issues
with the next move what should he play
here keeping in mind that you also need
to be aware of constant deform that my
transpose into a mainline a very
important thing is that the move Bishop
f5 which is perfectly normal in the
position where the pawn would be on d4
and one of the nights might nights is
not played that this movie has a very
important drawback after this exchange
there is this attacked and this attacked
twice and here black really am has yeah
it does not have a satisfactory move he
will lose the porn or need to move the
bishop back all the way to see ate
something like Queen B 6 is just as I
losing a pawn because of the track
intermediate check him
so Bishop f5 is not good at all and
white has some tricky ideas if black for
example plays e6 and this actually would
be announced if the Pawn would be on d4
already so the random variation or even
a six is what he has played countless
times but why does not need to play d4
he can sir delay the move or even avoid
it altogether by starting with b 3 there
are funny lines that's just for for
example put something on the board
something like that as possible and here
White has various ideas connected with
long castles and g4 you can even play d4
right here to launch the direct assault
on the black king and if you note to
part of this is just the type of line
that he might come up with so on I
didn't want to do that he played night
bd7 and this has an interesting point
the point is that after Queen c2 which
still would aim for this type of idea as
i showed before that Queen c2 and this
is what the pile of plate can be
answered by the movie 5 so black is much
more ambitious here he occupies the
center and make sure that why does not
get this kind of setup that I showed
before with long castles yeah y term
does not have much choice here he
basically needs to take on d5 if he does
not then black might even advanced
further or she had simply complete the
development why takes here because of
one point as well black can not really
take with the C porn which would be the
desirable recaptured keeping more pieces
on the board with the slide space
advantage that black ass however it has
a concrete problem of course not be five
and 97's terribly awkward to meet if
black tries to block this with a move
like in Bishop c5 you even have to
reckon with something like before and
this is really ugly now something like
that it's nothing you really want to
analyze really really oh wow okay so
black must take with the night and this
is what he did and here I'm to part of
the plate deform this has been played
before this position but Dee for is
really round they have been games with
Bishop e2 or a3 which however seems very
meek I mean white can certainly play
that but it's not aiming for anything
substantial d4 is just more
straightforward and it develops and this
is in fact the new rules that has been
introduced him in this game I'm not sure
how much our foam prep this is because
it still feels like a rather obscure
line but it's possible that this is part
of of annids preparation maybe not for
this particular game but part of his
general repertoire this type of move
order trickery is quite common nowadays
so you need to be aware of those things
on this level yeah why especially fix a
remarkable or somewhat interesting
novelty yeah simply because it it
basically entails a pawn sacrifice you
don't see it right away but it actually
sacrifices a pawn & 2 pi love takes that
he takes on e5 and now black come just
recaptured take stakes and now I played
the move Queen e four so he's really
testing this this novelty with the most
critical muth Queenie 4s the we move
attacking this bishop and using this um
configuration on the foul black only has
one move to not lose this piece in this
is queenie seven yeah and here we see
that why does indeed winning upon
takes d5 cd5 and t he decided to play a
move Bishop to b5 check which makes
sense because black now cannot really
reply with Bishop d7 which is the
natural replied advice why just take him
King takes and then he takes magnify
with the check and here on black really
is just material down he played king
evade it looks awkward at first but it's
not a big deal as we see why turn out
takes the pawn of course and now g 60
black quickly gets the King to g7 and
then he will gain even more time on
White's pieces especially the Queen on
d5 can easily be attacked with the later
roop d8 after King g7 or at one point
also Bishop e6 might be on course this
is hanging of it this is the idea what
even gains time a black even gains more
time because those pieces can be
attacked the bishop as well as always
for instance a 62 to kick it if you want
so it Bishop d2 was played an important
features of course that this Bishop is
always eyeing the b2 pond and this is
generally very active him yeah black
plate King g7 now if you look at this
rook be one that's very awkward because
the simple retreat fails to Bishop
before and white wins King g7 was the
idea anyway so what should I do now he's
upon up but how do you continue the game
now if you look at some normal-looking
moves let's say Cassens okay rook the
edge what have you gained this is not
this piece unless wide opts for this fun
I tactic yeah and we see that in the
game the parlor is going for this tactic
Queen takes
right away yeah instead of castling
because this enters the end game and it
does not make make so much sense to ya
22 just castle out of it you can rather
use the king in the middle and it seems
that he felt that he needs to do this
anyway queen takes d5 and so we went for
it now with the King not being committed
to the to the King side it's actually
difficult to to make any headway without
Queenie five if you look at let's say
bishops III for example black takes
place oops route yet and now where's the
Queen supposed to go it's not easy let's
say queen here how do you defend this
now this is also attacked White has some
some really serious coordination issues
queen bee three the screen g5 attacking
the pawn keeping an eye on the bishop
yeah castles immediately do this which
is the normal moves so black has really
substantial compensation so I guess that
we take c5 was a good decision it
simplifies to this end game black and
Bishop e6 yeah and here white enjoys an
extra poem but if you couldn't study it
a bit more carefully you see that black
really quickly boots up enormous
pressure on the queenside this is some
fairly typical occurrence in some
openings that white gets this four
against three that has this broken Queen
side and has a hard time to not allow
the exchange of all these pawns like
these pawns it's a bit much like all the
Queen's icons will be exchanged this is
in general here blacks idea he wants to
get rid of all his pawns and at the end
to draw the endgame upon down on the
Kings side and in fact this is very
young difficult for why
too often to avoid we can get similar
positions in the Queens gambit Rogozin
for example they're black often destroys
widescreen side but loses a pawn in the
process or in the groom thoughts this
can also sometimes happen that you get
this type of position on and let's look
at concrete movie played kini to rook
ACH of course attacking the weakness it
is defended Roxy five with the temple
important one loses a move here and rook
c8 and we see and the counter play is
coming really quickly played rook a
three white can try to cover it with the
king but at the end you will get your
checks and it will lead nowhere now as
they even something better I'll plug
here has even this move that sir that's
really annoying look at this this is
even losing straight away okay yeah y
term how has a hard time to play this if
let Luke a three and now like I so
active they're probably just yeah um
doing nothing is sufficient because
white has a hard time to improve but he
played it in the most straightforward
way a six and b5 I like it it's just the
most straightforward way to play by term
basically must exchange and now black
has the thread before yet this even
without the extra exchange but black now
threatens before what what should why do
actually to par law firm place the most
sensible move playgroup be one and yeah
here black takes on c3 of course and
white takes on b5 in both cases for both
captures the important thing is that
black gets the bishop traded that's very
very important
you want rook arrogant game here if you
don't want to an end game with with
bishops now this is almost not sure is
it is it a complete win for 44 again
three years probably as flat-out win for
the bishop or for the bishops um so
black wants a rookie rook endgame and
you get exactly the rook endgame here
this is a rook endgame obviously and
this in the game also gets down to rook
endgame and here we have it the
classical rogue and Game four against
three points which has been played yeah
thousands of times certainly and yeah
which generally speaking is a draw but
of course it is usually played out and
because it's one of those three roles
where white can just try and never is
going to never ever is going to lose a
game um yeah it is a draw but but why
exactly the problem is that pawn
advances on the King side which is the
only winning try usually lead to further
exchanges and at the end at the end in
like let's say 20 30 40 moves you
probably get position where white has
just one porn left a single porn and
this is never going to be a win with the
black king in front of one of those
pawns that this is a very easy defense
so um the draw is almost unavoidable
here with good defense what actually is
a good defense and that's just one thing
that is a very useful to know if the
defender is able to put a pawn on h5
that's usually very helpful it's a very
good defensive formation and for the
side with the extra porn it is normally
very helpful to have G floor plate
because g4 controls those important
squares and makes exchange is a bit more
difficult so
um if you theoretically would make ytl
can make two moves you would probably
play a tree and g4 to get this in
possibly later even g5 and only then f4
and advanced slowly in this type of
configuration is not so easy to directly
exchange corns like if it is black
smooth he would play age five so let's
see what the power of did he played king
of three the same idea he wants to play
g4 and what is are not doing page 5 of
course this is second nature to to a
good player to just put the pawns there
and now it is very tricky for white to
get get anywhere because you need to
advance your whole pawn mass and one of
those moves is g4 and it's always a
trait like just we'll just take it
unless there's some some good reason not
to but this is the general way to defend
like wants to exchange all pawns yeah
let's see what what happened rook is
active here on the second rank and are
not just puts up an active defensive
formation that makes it makes him being
able to exchange many pawns on fo I can
take a pawn on g4 you can take upon yeah
that's not much that white could try he
played like this and here of course
blank also takes King takes and just
wreck just stays active on the
second-ranked end there is no nothing to
to do here really the H porn and f1 will
be taken if they aren't once and that's
it yeah this is to pollow's last try you
move the e porn but we see that black
has a good control over those squares
and jam it was after
move that yeah he gave the check and now
the paula played the moon's group g2
yeah this is a quite a funny case
normally you never want to exchange
rooks in the rook endgame where you are
porn down because the king and porn and
game with the porn down is almost always
lost but almost the key word here here
in fact the rook trade check is what on
our plate and it is a dead wrong you
only need to be a somewhat somewhat
accurate with your move orders but why
does getting nowhere here Black is just
too active King f2 King a form this kind
of moves and here of course black must
play one important movie cannot just
drop back this is of course losing but
he can play a five and this draws the
game white needs to take chicken I
edgewise very simple but if you look at
this black it's just staying put you and
white has can make no headway it it was
check ended after that with backings on
the board which is always good for the
commentator because you don't need to
explain why they came ended in a draw so
we have a well fought game here it seems
that this was relatively easy draw
planet here of course all the porn down
but the compensation was pretty quickly
getting a parent and to follow really
after going into that [ __ ] was clear
that it was almost impossible to get
anything out of this ending if you look
at it with a computer for example like a
like Houdini it's always on 000 it also
sees that this end game four against
three is simply it simply dead so I'm
pretty easy draw for not what I think is
a good sign for a fan
of the former world champion is look at
his time time management he was playing
this or quickly and confidently of
course it's not rocket science to play
those moves but still a player like like
him who had really a bad run in the last
yeah let's say yes almost might have
somewhat shaken confidence but it does
not look like that he played a played
this very confidently and turned quickly
log in his former years where he was
known to play very fluently very quickly
so a draw him good good for both players
i guess to palo firm yeah he got this
extra point out of the opening which was
not enough but it happens still a game
where he never ever was in some risk of
losing so i guess i'm ok alright thanks
for watching